do you realize one policy by a president
can destroy 90% of mainstream media you
know what this policy is let me break it
down for you Patrick Bet David founder
and CEO of PHP one of the top Insurance
firms in America entrepreneur author and
the creator of value tainment on YouTube
everybody knows him Patrick Bet David
Patrick Bet David Patrick Bet David this
is a very chaotic year 2024 so how do
you capitalize and the fact that we're
CBS we're ABC we're such and such no no
no guess what we're Mr Beast we're sea
canel we're this Joe Rogan this is going
to flip in ways nobody is expecting the
future looks bright for those who create
great content this is just a beginning
for us I learned a long time ago guys
who take their game to a whole different
level when I say level I'm talking Brady
status musk status Jordan status they
have a combination of three things that
others don't have welcome back to the th
media podcast I'm sitting here with
Patrick B David and just a few hours ago
we started to kind of rally in Instagram
DMS talk to Mario on his team here we
are on a private jet you just got done
speaking in Vegas yes and we made this
happen yes so I'm fired up you're back
on the podcast we want to talk about uh
choose your enemies wisely you got a new
book um want to talk about YouTube this
2024 what are your predictions and
strategies for Content creators business
owners but I actually got to get your
opinion do you think Elon just destroyed
X formerly Twitter he uh told
advertisers to go f themselves because
they pulled ad Revenue because he made
some comments that were kind of
endorsing an anti-semitic story kind of
even a like a a pro-nazi post he said
that he he kind of like if you threaded
it he sort of clarified his thoughts but
nevertheless do you think he's being
flagrant do you think it's no big deal
it's all going to blow over do you think
it was a strategy what are your thoughts
so when you're one of one
you get away with things that others
don't get away with number two when you
have a reputation of coming through and
winning and disrupting the marketplace
you have a level of confidence in
yourselves that other don't others don't
number three when you're doing it for a
vision and a cause that's not money
you're not doing it for money you don't
need to be begging people for money you
know how much power there is in the word
no think about the power of no not the
power of yes but the power of no he's
telling advertisers that are telling him
to have a certain position go f yourself
do you realize like for the longest time
these guys are mobsters they control
they say things like to Media like a CNN
or an MSNBC or CBS or ABC or ESPN saying
hey your host the other day said this
he's got to kind of back down a little
bit with that hey that guy will paying
you $100 million per year he can't say
that again she's got to take that out
again so these companies are controlled
by these advertisers they know white the
other day talk talked about what he did
with pelaton and this company we're
having a meeting with him here and he's
telling her the story when he brought in
uh broadis anheiser Bush he said there
was this other company telling me hey
you can't say good things about that guy
or El said who the hell you think you
are to tell me what to do this it's
flipped today the flip today's
advertisers are no longer able to put
the fear into these guys with the money
that they could control for the longest
time because they're showing backbone do
you know how attractive it is for
somebody to have backbone for somebody
to come back and say no you can't
control me you can't do this to me what
elon's been doing he goes from being the
Guai everybody admires and they want to
go you know follow him and be like him
and a year and a half ago whatever
October of last year he buys Twitter he
starts saying things on Twitter then he
becomes the most hated man in business
and he can't do anything wrong in their
eyes but a guy like him is going to win
and he's going to Prevail and he's going
to find plenty of True Believers that
want to work for him I read a headline
that said the mainstream media is
dying um what shifts do you see
happening you're talking about that
things are shifting and you're a
disruptor yourself what's your opinion I
I love the fact that they're they're
sitting there scared do you realize one
policy by president can destroy 90% of
mainstream media you know what this
policy is let me break it down for you
watch this so if all of a sudden the
president goes out there and says hey
American people do you know how many
countries in the world allow
pharmaceutical companies to advertise on
TV and social media how many two two I
didn't know that yeah do you know what
those two countries are what America and
New Zealand why New Zealand so Germany
doesn't no Canada doesn't allow no Italy
no Spain Brazil no Russia no UK no it's
only us and New
Zealand why not well because
pharmaceutical companies are giving so
much money to these Med media companies
and these media company announcers and
hosts and talent have to do whatever
they can with these pharmaceutical
companies because if they don't a lot of
the profit of these big media companies
coming from who Pharma big Pharma so
what if a president goes out there and
does an executive order saying moving
forward pharmaceutical companies can no
longer advertise just like you know what
company can't advertise on TV today they
can sell their product but you never see
their commercials on TV what is it
when's the last time you saw a cigarette
commercial when's the last time you saw
a Bape commercial
president makes the case and you and I
sit there and we're like you know what
he's got a good point she's got a good
point why are we allowing this why
should we allow him to do this kind of
stuff why don't you allow the doctor to
make the recommendation to me and I'll
take the counsel from the doctor but I
don't need a billion dollars of
advertising budget for you know this
Pharma thing that I got to take so to
me there's three things holding them
back one is Big Pharma advertising
number two is Boomers that still watch
TV and number three you know what the
last one is that scares the crap out of
mainstream media is the one thing they
have control of that basketball teams
like the Suns and Salt Lake Utah some of
these teams are disrupting it is called
Sports If Sports goes on digital Hulu
Amazon if sports teams say moving
forward you want to watch your sons Go
download the son Suns app it's 999 a
month and you can watch us what if the
Lakers go on their own app what if the
Knicks go on their own app what if Tampa
goes on their own app oh my God we don't
need the contracts anymore no what if
Super Bowl goes on all these other apps
and OT start giving those contracts so
mainstream media is shivering right now
with disruption and they're in the
begging mode but behind closed doors
some of these Oldtimer guys that are on
their way out they're like man we better
get our money look what happened to
Disney last 12 18 months they lost $195
billion give or take or valuation 56%
their stock is down Bob Iger just come
out came out today and said he's going
to be stepping on by 2026 here's one of
the greatest Executives we've had last
30 38 years 40 years has done some of
the biggest deals Pixar Star Wars who
he's bought everybody and now right of a
lifetime becomes finishing up the way
you are right now because you forgot who
your customer was you went from
realizing you know what the customer for
do you know when Disney's number one
customers the person who's got control
of the remote control who is that you
and I who are we we're parents not the
kids they forgot we're the customer how
does Bob Iger forget that you and I the
customer what happened to him the moment
you forget the number one rule know your
customer he forgot they're getting
destroyed backto backto back movies that
are flops so mainstream Medias uh is
being clobbered and guys like Elon Dana
sports team some of these other guys
couple policies if those things go
through their lifespan is 5 10 15 years
maybe shorter you bring up Sports and so
uh I'm curious if you heard this you're
a sports guy you just became part owner
owner of the New York Yankees yep um so
Marissa soless said this and she's
actually the SVP of global brand
consumer marketing of the NFL check this
out 33% of gen Z doesn't watch live
games and what the NFL has been doing
has been tapping into the Creator
economy to reach them so they're
collaborating with influencers they're
calling it The helmets off strategy
trying to Showcase Players on and off
one big example was Mr Beast had Tom
Brady on
you're always speaking into culture you
just talked about what happens if Sports
take things back what is your thoughts
about jz's behaviors if they're not
watching live games the NFL is trying to
Pivot to creators what do you think the
power of creators is and and maybe why
the NFL as a as a corporation is doing
this they have no choice I mean Mr Beast
does a video gets 80 million views 100
million you don't have a choice the
Super Bowl's 104 million views so think
about a Kai that starts a YouTube
channel got three 400 million
subscribers does a video gets 100
million views and you are the NFL your
name is Roger godell and you say to
advertise well let me tell you the
reason why it's so important to spend
$5.2 million for a 30 second commercial
on Super Bowl it's because you get 104
million people watching it's the most
watched sporting event in America right
but these young guys are no longer
watching it where are they getting their
stuff they're maybe watching highlights
they're just going watching re maybe
they're watching post game they kind of
want the fastest thing to get so they
got to go get the younger people to be
participating look what happened all of
a sudden all these Chiefs games are
selling out why all these you know
everywhere they go on the road Jets
wherever they go s because Taylor Swift
is dating Travis Kelce and Taylor
Smith's got a few hundred million
followers they're understanding who's in
charge and they do not like that this is
a scary Direction it's going those who
pivot and adjust accordingly will win
but the days of bullying are behind us
the days of guys leveraging their pulpit
and the fact that we're CBS we're ABC
we're such and such no no no guess what
we're Mr Beast we're Sean canel where
this Joe Rogan where this this oh my God
we kind of need those guys to come and
help us out with this of course they are
this is going to flip in ways nobody is
expecting except for guys like you guys
like us who are content creators the
future looks bright for those who create
great content this is just a beginning
for us yeah yeah and so you have some
predictions and some thoughts about 2024
yes let's go macro first and then let's
go specific for creators so macro what
are your predictions you just mentioned
those who if you don't pivot you're in
trouble so how do we prepare what do you
see coming so first of all it's going to
be very chaotic year I mean you're
you're going to see uh uh Trump Biden
you saw yesterday Nome Des santis
politically it's going to be crazy
interest rates corporations is having to
pay their payments if interest rates
don't go down people are worried if
interest rates do go down let's just say
right now mortgage rates are at 7 and a
qu 30 year fix you got a 720 740 let's
say it's 7 and A5
per. if rates and by the way Real Estate
Value hasn't drop it keeps going higher
so they're increasing the rates and real
estate value is still going higher and
people are not selling comes because
they're not dropping a 2.85 3% interest
rate that they got a year and a half ago
two years ago but what happens if all of
a all of a sudden they lower the rates
what happens if Powell is forced to
lower the rates what happens there these
real estate values are going to
Skyrocket so what happens if it
skyrockets the whole concept of the rich
got rich and the poor got poor it's
going to be on steroids what happens the
next 12 months on steroids you could
potentially the IPO Market's going to
come back in 2024 you're going to see
the IP Market in 2023 is it's one of the
worst IP Seasons we ever had 2023
horrible
2024 you're going to see some IPOs
coming out 2025 on fire if somebody on
the right gets elected as a president if
you remember the day Trump got elected
as a president stock market the next day
boom skyrocketed way before he even did
anything with policies today uh the left
is not happy with the president that
they have the right is not happy happy
with the president that the left has
today with Joe Biden the numbers are not
looking good it's so bad right now that
yesterday a governor from Florida who's
running for president is debating a
governor from California Nome who's not
running for office right now why are
they on the stage do they know something
the rest of us don't know this is a very
chaotic year 2024 so how do you
capitalize when Co happened what
happened all of a sudden next thing you
know meet Kevin 1.5 million subscribers
wow this guy's great well who is this
guy oh Graham Stefan who is that guy
people were popping up left and right
and they were doing daily lives and
here's what's going on let me give you
an update on this let me give you an
update on this 20124 if it's a chaotic
year the talent who is able to react to
comments quickly and get creative and
start using some of this new AI that's
coming out that's allowing you to import
a three-hour podcast that you did and
this AI spits out your top 20 clips and
which one it edits it for you it puts
video over it it puts captions over it
it gives you title in a description to
post so what if the guys that are
talented people and they have an angle
that's different than others and they
leverage AI I think I think it's a very
weird year 2024 in a positive way and
whenever people are afraid which a lot
of people are going to be afraid in 2024
F sharpens listening 2024 is going to be
year a lot of people going to be afraid
so your founder CEO value tment you guys
are pumping out do you know how much
content you're popping out I honestly
couldn't tell you I know it's a lot of
stuff right now I I think I think 50 to
100 upload uploads on across multiple
channels couple podcasts a week two
three podcasts a week yeah I so we so I
do pbd podcast we'll do two minimum a
week unless I'm out of town sometimes
we'll do three then he got vment comedy
they do their things and he got sauce
cast then he got Unusual Suspect then
you got vtsc you got a few other things
that we're doing and we cut all those
stuff in short clips and so we got a lot
of stuff that's going on we got body
tment that I'm doing the how-to on
Monday on Wednesday it's a lot of stuff
that's going on right now so 2020 for
what are some of your thinking for
Content creators and maybe first for the
upstart because you're at I mean we're
at a different scale you're at a whole
different scale and some people are
trying to figure out a side hustle speak
to them and then we'll talk to about
media companies at scale got it so
somebody that's getting started look at
everybody on the marketplace and S give
everybody a score here's what I mean by
it so you know how in baseball this guy
named uh uh Billy Bean uh the movie
Moneyball with Brad Pit right the guy
Billy Bean is the only guy I brought to
events three times I love interviewing
this guy and he never lets me interview
him it's the only thing we love doing it
but he never wants his stuff to be
recorded for whatever reason no problem
I respect it so in baseball they say
this guy is a five tool player he's fast
he's a good hitter he's a good Defender
B so he's a five tool player right in
content creation there is the concept of
five tool except maybe it's not five
tool it's three tool it's four tool but
there's different tool so for example in
podcasting there are guys that are very
good interviewers they ask very good
questions okay there are guys that only
ask the questions that chat gbt pops out
what they don't realize is a great
interviewer ask the follow-up question
so not the first question but the second
one how did you feel about that what do
you think about this what about if this
happens what about if that happens chat
GPT doesn't tell you the reaction
questions right but some people are very
good interviewers number two
some people are entertaining they're
funny they're comedian or they got this
temper or they got an animated way of
explaining whatever they're so the
personality is you're just attracted by
these guys like w that guy's a very
interesting guy I want to know more
about the guy then the third factor of
somebody that's doing interviews is good
questions entertaining the next one is
you're sexy you're attractive you got
muscles you got nice body you got all
this stuff so if you got use it right
good-look people on camera it helps you
as well there's a lot of people that got
millions of followers because they're
attractive but nobody cares about the
content you're just hot as hell right so
then the last one is somebody that is
also very very good with their opinions
so I want to know what does this guy
think interesting very interesting angle
so for example Joe Rogan you watch him
he's entertaining he's funny you like
his personality he can talk content on
different levels so you follow the guy
look I actually really want to hear what
this guy has to say so your opinion
could be sports like all of a sudden Pat
McAfee is doing sports and talking about
what's going on and you know Aaron
Rogers is on his podcast every week and
the next thing you know Spotify picks
him up and then boom ESPN picks him up
and he's getting paid all this money
what happened all of a sudden the guy
had a personality he was different he
was fired up he's got big personality
he's asking the tough questions he's got
strong opinions criticism of the league
he's got all of that stuff he's like a
five tool content creator right so you
have to look at as a starter what angle
you going to take that's different than
others and on the content side write
down topics you're very good at and I
see how many layers you can go deep on
so for example I used to ask myself okay
let me see if I'm good into business
topics then I would watch a podcast guy
on business and he's interviewing
somebody and he asked him the question I
would say pause how would you answer it
I would answer it this way write it down
okay now let's see how he answers it
okay I think your answer is better Okay
cool so you can hang with this guy next
question boom how would you answer pause
here's how I would answer it click now
his answer is better you're kind of
checking to see what level of expertise
you got on topics so then you realize I
can't go that deep on this topic but I
can go deep on these two topics and the
market the more multi-dimensional you
are to go seven eight nine layers deeper
the more of an audience you're going to
have so some audience for vam they'll
come and say man I want L your mob
interviews okay hey I love your business
content man I started being an
entrepreneur ever since I watch value
tainment I love your political stuff I
love the podcast opinions you got on
what's going on I like your take on
business I like what you're doing with
Iran I like your interviews with
bodybuilding if you are wider with areas
you can go deeper on there's a market
for it so if you're small getting
started kind of look where you are
yourself ask others what your topics are
and then find a way to see where you're
a differentiator at and then go test it
you're never going to know what's going
to happen but you go test it and then
you're like you know what two years
later I only had a th000 subscribers
most people don't realize this I did
this for two years after you started
value tment years later two years later
only a thousand go look at the numbers I
started November of 2012 first video two
years later November 2014 we only have a
th000 subscribers when life of an
entrepreneur came out in 1992 that video
was uploaded October 30th I'll give you
the exact date of 2015 if you go look at
the channel October 30th of 2015 I've
already been there for 3 years we only
have 2,000 subscribers the video goes
out I put the title best motivation
video of the year it only gets 2500
views I put it on Facebook direct upload
when Facebook first came out with this
it gets 10 million views the first 24
hours that goes viral and then we went
to 15,000 subscribers 20,000 then I
interviewed Mark cubin then this thing
goes to 100,000 so you can't be sitting
there saying wow look a Shan's got you
know this many millions of these guys
are doing this that guy's doing that at
a th000 Subs after two years okay so you
can't go doing this expecting you're
going to have a million with within a
year so now let's talk about media
companies maybe people got money maybe
yep um if you got money do you go big
first or do you still kind of bootstrap
no there's a lot of guys that would to
spend a quarter million dollars a month
buying subscribers you know who they are
I know who they are how are they doing
today Gone Gone you know why because
those subscribers bought you because you
were spending money but you're no longer
interesting you were just in their faces
so if you are able to get subscribers
without doing any ads and they show up
because your content is that great where
people are sharing it now you have real
fans that are staying with you don't get
me wrong like for us if I we spend money
on ads we're only doing ads because it's
Bal conference or BPW or we have SLS
coming up or we're doing an ad for our
app that we just launched man M NN eect
man you can ask me any questions DM me a
text or video or have a 50-minute call
with me and you pay for it by the minute
we'll do ads on that but we don't do ads
on YouTube channels okay we don't do ads
on that we may do in the future but we
haven't done it right now because first
go on the right see if you're
interesting see people like you see if
you're doing good then you're like okay
so some guys well I got 200,000
subscribers and I'll go and say yeah but
I look at your last 30 videos 293 views
998 views dude Peep and then I go all
the way to the back oh he has that one
video at 48 million views oh it was an
ad to a funnel I got you that's not real
250,000 Subs it's a different 250,000
Subs so if you're solving for a funnel
to sell a project product great but if
you're doing it because you want to be
an
influencer you have to go through the
grind of whether you can make it on by
the way you and I did it without AI we
didn't have ai we didn't have Chad GPT
we didn't have any of that stuff you're
just kind of testing today people can do
it 10 times faster than you and I
because they have better tools than we
had we didn't have these tools these
tools are making things very easy today
but the edge that we had is the audience
we got are actually audience we worked
very very hard for so that's the only
disadvantage guys that come in with
money and they're thinking they're
winning but it's it's fake you're not
you're not really winning hey we're
about to get back into the podcast in
just a second but I have a question for
you do you want to grow your personal
brand this year do you need more leads
and sales in your business if the answer
is yes then right now is the best time
to go all in on YouTube Today's podcast
is brought to you by think
masterclass.com where you can get
OnDemand access to a onehour deep dive
training revealing how to start and grow
a profitable YouTube channel this year
for a limited time you can get access to
this on demand class entirely for free
where you will learn the three biggest
mistakes that people make when starting
a YouTube channel the new rules and
changes that have been happening on
YouTube and how you can use them to
create an unfair advantage and the exact
strategy we use at think media to
generate over
350,000 organic views every single day
the data is clear 70% of viewers claim
that YouTube makes them more aware of
new brands so don't wait any longer to
start growing your brand and business
with YouTube just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to this no
fluff highly tactical free onDemand
training that's
masterclass.com we're going to talk
about enemies in a second but as the
author of your next five moves which
just continues to grow grow more
momentum I was watching you when we were
doing uh your Elite coaching and I'm
learning and you pull up your screen you
have multiple books on top charts right
now and that's one of my favorite books
your next five moves knowing that you're
always thinking moves ahead with a media
company with real fans with real
momentum you mentioned a couple things
AI if you summarized a few things 2024
what moves are you thinking in media
yeah that's a good question so to me
right now all I'm thinking about uh by
the way can you see if Mario has a copy
to choose your enemies wisely somewhere
over there if one of you guys can give
it to me Mario I think you got it or Sam
if you can grab a copy of it so the only
thing on my mind right now Sean only
thing when it coming down to all the
companies we're running is hiring nines
and tens that's all I'm thinking about
all I'm thinking about is thank you all
I'm thinking about right now is hiring
nines and tens what do I mean by that um
we just hired an executive
from uh Disney who'll be starting with
us December 11th I was in LA yesterday
at catch sitting down with another
executive who work directly with
somebody you definitely know that's a
Fortune 50 company and these guys are
very expensive hires they're not cheap
hires the salaries are very expensive so
for me I'm not not accustomed to this
yet to hire people like this but while
I'm reading you know Steven
schwartzman's whatever it takes and this
guy's a 30 billion guy or you read no
rules rules and you're seeing how these
guys build their Empires they brought
people in that they had to pay big
dollars for so we're getting the system
of creating a culture with the right
benefits to attract those eights nines
and tens and then at the same time being
able to give them an opportunity that
maybe an apple or a Disney or a Amazon
or Netflix cannot offer because they're
already 200 billion companies so that
$200 billion company being worth a
trillion dollars do you want to wait 10
years what if I come to a company that's
worth $200 million and I take that
company to be a $50 billion company holy
what is that Equity work so I'm
recruiting that talent to put a super
team together all I'm thinking about
right now is putting our Avengers
together we don't have them yet but
that's what we're doing and maybe not
everybody can get nines and tens but
build a team get some help
100% I think I think one of the things
you did like when I look at your eyes
right now it's different eyes than I see
when I saw the eyes of two years ago and
I think you agree you just turned 40
years old yeah happy birthday to you
thank you but you're fresher younger and
hungrier today than you were at 38 so
what so what happened because you
finally are like you're rich you're a
multimillionaire you made money you got
a good life you contribute to your
church you live in a nice place you got
your family you're an influencer you got
respect when you go places so what
happened to you even a guy like you
where you're at where some people like
I'd love to be a Sean kenel you
recreated yourself right you're like
here's what I want to be going through
your team's bigger you're about to have
your retreat you're excited about your
three four day Retreat what happened you
got your vision clear and you said I got
to go find my guys that we can build
this incredible team together with right
anybody watching this it's you don't
have an assistant go get your assistant
you don't have an editor go get an
editor
you don't have a shooter go get the
shooter but you got to be thinking about
recruiting that Talent of yours to start
helping you grow exponentially you can't
do it by
yourself choose your enemies wisely yes
new book by the time this drops because
this comes out December 5th 5th so this
this is probably all happening at the
same time of course we'll link it up the
no I already pre-ordered a couple copies
read uh we'll link that up in the show
notes what does it mean what does choose
your enemy's wife mean I learned a long
time ago guys who take their game to a
whole different level when I say level
I'm talking Brady status musk status
Jordan
status they have a combination of three
things that others don't have number one
thing they have they have experienced
unconditional love from one person the
best thing about experiencing
unconditional love from one person is
the following say this person is your
mother typically for a man it's their
mom for a woman sometimes their dad what
is unconditional love you come home
drunk they forgive you you crash their
car they forgive you you embarrass them
in front of their family they chew you
out but they forgive you and they still
love you and you're in the car by
yourself you just talk rudely to your
mom and she calls you saying baby
whatever you do tonight just don't mommy
loves you I know you're upset with me
and you ask yourself this question
you're like how the hell can this person
love me the way she does so what does
that do to you for the rest of your life
you're willing to risk having
relationships with people because you've
experienced unconditional love one time
you have to experience that or else
you're afraid to risk that right number
two second thing you need
is someone in your life that you loved
that shattered your heart that destroyed
your heart nothing you could ever do you
will earn or gain that person's approval
nothing six-pack
bench five plates become a millionaire
billionaire buy the biggest house become
a sports owner does marry the hottest
girl does not matter you are never going
to win this person over that's pain you
need a lot of that pain and last but not
least you know what it is is choose your
enemies wisely most people don't choose
their enemies wisely there's so many
examples of choosing The Wrong Enemy uh
Bob ier right now is choosing The Wrong
Enemy he's choosing us as an enemy we're
not the freaking enemy we're your ally
we're your number one customer we want
you to succeed we want better cartoons
we want better movies we grew up
watching this kind of stuff we want you
to do better but he chose us as enemies
or maybe the board chose us as enemies
big mistake Blockbuster chose no enemies
they weren't intimidated about Netflix
they didn't think they were going to
come after him they're like nah 50
million bucks they chose the customers
as enemies 17 days 3.99 late fee big
mistake there's so many examples of that
but if you get the right enemy you know
like we're talking about this when it
comes on to books I as a person that's
Consulting a lot of people and coaching
a lot of people I like to have books to
recommend for the individual to go read
that will help them resolve the next
issue they're going through hey
leadership book what do you recommend go
read this book by Max book go read this
book on linkoln on leadership hey I'm
going through a hard time right now I
want some biographies go read musk's
book go read schwartzman's book go read
right of a life to of Bob Iger go read
all these okay I'm trying to go raise
money and I'm trying to get into private
Equity what do I do read Buffett's book
read Monger book read cr's book I'm
trying to get married and should I get
go read 101 questions to ask before we
get engaged I'm trying to all of this
stuff I want a book recommendation you
know there's not a book right now you
can recommend to anybody when it comes
on to business planning not one when I
saw that I didn't have people who want
to I don't want to write this book I
want the book to be there so I give it
to you but if it's not there I'm going
to write the book hey Pat I'm going to
write a business I want a book every
year for people to read in December for
business planning this doesn't exist
whether you're a billionaire millionaire
athlete a politician a pastor getting
started this book teaches you the 12
building blocks of writing a business
plan six logical six emotional to get
you the biggest rate of return with the
plan where you don't just write it set
of the side you write it you like dude
this is absolutely amazing that's why I
wrote this book choose your enemies
wisely if you're a mom what's an example
of an enemy are you kidding me public
education what they're doing to your
kids you know cartoons Netflix you know
YouTube uh um Apple uh politicians in
different states California Newsome you
know governors in different states local
school administrators principls you know
your District you're you know whatever
District you're in that's choosing to
put certain books in there I can give
you a list of enemies for a mom out
there that gets them pissed off so for a
mom that sister and says I am so sick
and tired of what they're doing to my
kids guess what Mom run for something go
run for something go run for office in
your school you'd be amazed how much of
a chance you got of doing something with
that get together with 50 other moms and
say guys which one of he wants to run if
you don't want to run I'll run but
someone's got to run and we got to be on
the board because this is a show
right now in the school no problem Mary
you want to run I'm so busy Becky do you
want to run no okay why don't we do this
let's all write names on who we want to
run go ahead put it in there da d d okay
Mary got 19 votes oh my God Mary we want
you to run let's support you let's go
boom we put her in the school now you're
changing now you're protecting books
that book can't be here this book can't
be there there's a list of them but uh
our public school education right now is
horrible and what they're doing to our
kids is dangerous moms have many many
many enemies that I'm sure drives them
insane they got to use that force and
energy to unite and do something about
it if they do their kids will be
protected if they don't they could
potentially lose their kids to some
pathetic mindsets for the next decade or
two which is scary and the language of
enemies because that makes total sense
it's totally clear but how would you
bridge that for someone that's like what
are they my
enemy yeah they might have that level of
aggression if you're yeah totally fine
listen uh you can be passive or tolerant
or you know I just don't like that word
you know like it's the word hate we
never use word hate no problem the other
night I'm having dinner with my family
and my son Dylan who's super
competitive but he hates certain things
so I asked him a question I said D I got
a question for you about competition
what's that Daddy I said Do You Love
winning or do you hate losing half a
second he thinks about it he says that I
hate losing I look at Jen I'm like babe
I told you some of the greatest winners
in the world are the ones who hate
losing so what do they do they're overly
prepared they overtrain they overread
they over prepare because they're not
going to be publicly humiliated they
lost the game Kobe goes back to the gym
makes another thousand shots he's ready
for the next day he missed three free
throws he's not going to do it again the
next day this concept of hating to lose
is a powerful thing so hate isn't from
the hate that people I hate shie no
whatever you don't hate you will learn
to tolerate and there's way too many
tolerant Christians that are ruining
America today so stop being so tolerant
and start identifying your enemies want
to take away what you love they want to
confuse them they want to take that away
from you it's on you to use the fuel of
their enemies because if you're going to
be so tolerant you know what they're
going to do they're going to chize off
your tolerance they're going to be like
oh I'm so glad he's tolerant I interview
this guy I don't know if I told you
about it the last time we sat down
together this guy who was
a uh child uh uh what he called
pedophile he does 12 years in jail comes
out and he's willing to agree to an
interview and the guy starts asking
asking him questions the girl ask him
questions so so who are your targets and
he says oh any family that doesn't
believe in God any family that the
father's not involved any family where
you know the mom and dad don't watch
what the kids are doing any family that
allows me to take their kids to maybe
sit them or play sports with them that
they're not really caring if they're
going to be with me at the park those
are the targets for me but if the
father's involved if the family's a
Christian with values and principles and
if they have siblings that love each
other
I can't Target those families that's an
enemy if that doesn't piss you off in
your belly what do you call that do you
say let's be tolerant with this person
that is the most pathetic thing I've
ever heard no we have to be a little bit
paranoid we have to be a little bit you
know protective of the people that are
in our lives we only have them for 18
years we only have them for that long so
for me yeah stop being so sensitive when
it comes on to words like enemies um
because they definitely are very
comfortable looking at you as an
enemy there's uh there's real evil in
the world our uh uh my pastor in the
Pacific Northwest Russell Johnson The
Pursuit Northwest Church just started a
political action committee leaves in
prayer leaves in preaching but doesn't
we got to get involved though we
actually got to got to get involved so
you mentioned some things for moms
pastors and just that we can't be
passive we got to get active content
creators enemies
any different perspective obviously what
kind of content you're creating but you
know just trying to apply the book to
thinking about maybe content creators
feeling a little passive I know when I
get clear on an enemy you've helped me
do that I got a whole another level of
drive a whole another level of fire for
those that are locking that fire they
obviously can pick up the book but as
anything come to mind you're you're a
content creator or a framework to help
you maybe from the book identify okay oh
wow now I'm getting lit yeah so the the
easiest SE and in the book there's 10
different types of enemies that we talk
about in the book and how to use it
maximum but I'll give you the best
exercise I'm on a flight back from
Chicago and I have my yellow no pad and
I sometimes I love flying by myself
because I could think and really process
stuff that I was going through to take
you to the next level so I take the
yellow note that out and I start making
a list of the most offensive painful
comments remarks people I've said to my
face or behind my back and I saw writing
it that one time she said this to me
that one time that ex said this that one
time that relative said this my teacher
said this that former boss said this
that guy said this and at this point I'm
just like I get down to 20 30 maybe get
to 40 and then I start ranking and I'm
like which one gets me fired up to at
this point I'm on the flight I'm on fire
right I'm on this flight back and I'm
like oh this is number
one I what's number
two this is number two
this is number three this is four this
is five I get my 10 five or 10 and I
start reading it every flipping day so
rather than saying stuff like you're the
I'm proud of you I love you honey no the
opposite you ain't never going to do
with your life you're a loser
you're not going to make it without me
okay no one's ever going to marry you
who do you think you are you are so
lucky you had me you will never find a
girl better than me you will never find
a man better than me those comments are
making unbelievable right so you're a
content creator okay what have people
said about you first time I started
content one of my guys came up to me and
rumors started spreading in the
insurance company and they said Pat
wants to leave the insurance company
started and he wants to be a
motivational speaker three guys said it
my best guys by the way so I pulled them
and said I said hey guys you think I
want to be motivational speakers they
said yeah I said so why do you think I'm
creating this content so well you share
it with us I said oh I share it with you
so you think the videos I'm getting is
because I'm sending it in a text
distribution no problem moving forward I
will never send you a video you know
what happened I never ever once sent
them the video because I didn't want
them to think that I'm doing it to get
viewership you go to Vault events before
who the only people that can't come to
Vault events my guys from the insurance
company they cannot buy the ticket to go
why because I did not want them to think
I'm using them to get eyeballs you know
what that did to me it drove me in ways
I can't even describe that's subtle a
comment to say Pat wants to be a
motivational speaker I use it as fuel
there's so many different examples you
can find of what people say to you but
that's just the starters obviously when
you order a book choose your enemies
wisely yeah by the way in the Audio I
typically buy the physical and the AUD
audible because I tell some stories in
the audible that I didn't write in a
book which is sick but uh I them when
you order it I love it well listen we're
going to link up of course in the show
notes get the book get the audible get
both and choose your enemies wisely
uh pbd so grateful for you any shout
outs what's happening I mean roll call
we're going to 2024 how can people
engage get connected you know we're
going to the Vault we're bringing our
Executives to Vault like five six
executive tickets CEO ticket conference
changed my life last year for business
own what a community right how how
everybody is together yeah it's a very
interesting Next Level I mean in the
workbook and everything it really
challenged me at a whole another level
for uh leadership all that kind of stuff
but yeah what's up what what are you up
to I I if I to say anything like my I
have this bipolar relationship right
there's a side of me that's overly
paranoid or like hey careful with this
what about this and what about that and
what about this but an overwhelming side
of me is so flipping optimistic about
what's about to happen an overwhelming
side of me is excited about who's the
next Talent that's going to come out
that's going to do better than us I mean
you know we're sitting here talking what
you and I do is not one 100 of what Mr
Beast is is doing or one whatever the
number is right of what he's doing who
is this guy younger guy came in
Revolution as a multi-billionaire now
where you know big multi-billion dollar
Industries are cting a guy like that the
future looks I'm 45 years old so I'm on
the other side but there could be 20
year olds punching right now 18 years 14
years watching right now they're going
to take this type of content and do
stuff that were like oh my God that guy
used YouTube to become a president what
the game has changed it's a very
different time this is not a regular
time we
we haven't even figured out half the
ways of using these tools so I think I'm
watching kids very closely what they're
doing I'm watching 14 15 16 year olds
content creators to see what tools
they're using there's a whole different
segment right now to the marketplace
that we have to pay attention to we
can't fall for the Trap of I'm 45 do you
know who I am I'm a grown man you know
all this stuff many grown companies are
going bankrupt today because they think
they're grown companies being being
destroyed by younger companies this is
by far the worst time to think just
because you have experience you know
what the other guy does and you're going
to get blindsided soci mentality stay
learning stay humble you know staying
grateful mode you know keep your eyes
open keep your ears open and future
looks bright Patrick Bet David think
media podcast like share leave a review
appreciate you my man anytime anytime if
you enjoy this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1hour OnDemand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com